[Music]
do you get a buzz out of buying
something
a little tingle of excitement
it feels good doesn't it
that's your brain producing dopamine
it's the same rush you get from
chocolate or sex
during lockdown people were increasingly
forced to rely on the internet to get
their retail dopamine hits
in fact over 4 trillion dollars were
spent buying stuff online in 2020
almost a third more than the year before
shopping is going through a radical
shift right now and the pandemic has
sped it up
retailers have been forced to adapt and
innovate
driving this revolution you
or to be more specific your data
here's how
if you went shopping in the 16th century
you'd get personalized service
so for example if you wanted to buy your
suit of armor
you would go to an armorer who would
knock it up to your specifications
but bespoke services came with a premium
price tag
then came the industrial revolution with
its big factories assembly lines and
automation
mass production made goods cheaper but a
lot less personalized and distribution
was tricky
products had to be taken from factories
to what was essentially a small
warehouse near where the customers lived
basically a shop
the only way you could buy was through
these shops
and you had very little choice actually
you had very few shops near you and if
you wanted something you had to go your
choice was between one of those shops
fast forward to the advent of
superstores and out of town malls and
these choices grew
but everything changed when the internet
came along
suddenly the shopper has more choice
than ever and it's really up to the
producer and the retailer to offer the
consumer what they want when they want
it
with more choice came more power for the
consumer
30 years ago we in the brands used to
define the brand ourselves and the
product glossy ads like these have
pushed products to consumers for decades
and the consumers used to like so many
pavlov's dogs they used to come and buy
but the internet has put consumers in
the driving seat
calling the shots and what's cool and
what's not through reviews social media
posts and influencers
leading the way in this retail
revolution is china
this
is she's a huge live streaming star and
now i have 1.8 million followers on red
and they are just like my best friend
but unlike live streaming in the west
which is used mostly for entertainment
or gaming gutien vlogs to vlog
selling thousands of beauty products to
her 1.8 million social media followers
she's one of thousands of influencers
also known as key opinion leaders oh my
god selling anything from lipsticks to
food and even plants
live streaming selling has helped to
make china the world leader in
e-commerce
it's forecast that in 2021 half of
everything bought in china will be
bought online
for jinji and millennial like me most of
them prefer shopping online and going to
a physical store
because of
larger range of choices and lower price
the chinese internet market is
very very highly developed the scale of
the market is over two trillion dollars
worth of consumption online they have
something called singles day where they
do they do billions of dollars worth of
transactions in an hour
three huge companies dominate alibaba
jd.com
which combined account for almost 80
percent of the market
the other thing about the chinese market
that's very interesting is that whereas
we have like google in search and we
have facebook in social media amazon in
e-commerce
and paypal in payments
they've put it all together in single
organizations
so they have entire ecosystems and many
chinese consumers live their entire
lives in those ecosystems
[Applause]
these super app ecosystems give the
retailers intimate knowledge of exactly
what their users like want and buy
and of course
all of this
requires
a huge amount of data and the chinese
are much more willing at this point
to allow
data tracking of everything that they do
than
many people are in the west
with more direct insight into customer
demands
retailers can maximize their margins and
cut waste
some chinese tech firms are even using
people's digital footprint to influence
the way goods are produced
known as consumer to manufacturer
that's really cutting out even the
brands from the purpose so the factories
then start dealing directly with
consumers and of course can be flexing
their production capacity uh directly
depending on on the consumer demand
western retailers are playing catch-up
for years they rested on their laurels
regarding the internet as secondary to
the store
not help perhaps by the fact that they
had sunk a lot of money into store space
america for example has 2.2 square
meters of retail space for every single
one of its inhabitants
six times the level of china
but western retailers also missed a big
trick
their customers big data
retailers historically had very little
data about their individual customers
they used to have store credit cards
that was about it but the online
companies have huge amounts collected
huge amounts of data about their
customers when you consider that
against the uh the what the retailers
had the retailers and traditional brands
were really flying blind and that is why
the internet companies have beaten
the incumbent retailers and brands for
the most part over the last 20 years
the pandemic was a death knell for many
brands
8
700 stores were closed by big chain
retailers in america in 2020
but the companies that did harness the
power of their consumers data
are thriving amazon exceeded 100 billion
dollars in quarterly sales for the first
time ever in the last three months of
2020.
amazon of course wrote the book on
individual customer data and its uses
and of course as they got bigger and
bigger and bigger they've got more data
than anybody else with its established
logistical system and smooth purchasing
process
amazon may seem a useful online platform
for brands to peddle their wares
but though amazon passes on the sale to
the brand it doesn't pass on much of the
customers data
which means companies know very little
about who is buying their products
so some brands are cutting the amazon
cord to focus on what's known as direct
to consumer selling such as nike
it decided to sell only online via the
nike website
and
what it did then was it developed ways
of keeping much closer tabs on its
customers for example
a membership program
nike's loyalty scheme allows it to
create customer profiles of its 250
million members
70 million of whom join during the
pandemic
nike's apps offer the customer a
personalized experience in return for a
detailed insight into their behaviour
if you sign up to their app
you'll give them information about how
much you run every day what sports clubs
you're doing how much yoga you're doing
all that sort of stuff and this helps
inform nike about what to produce
they're able to see where you are and
that also informs the way they think
about where to put their stores
nike's apps let users customize their
own shoes and in doing so learn the
customer's favorite colours and designs
and by tracking how far they run can
even let the customer know when it's
time to splash out on a new pair of
shoes
you're sharing your data and your
intimacy with nike
it all basically creates a more intimate
bond between
nike and its customers
as shopping shifted online the pandemic
sparked a greater need for this type of
direct to consumer selling
enter shopify an e-commerce platform
which allows anyone to set up their own
online store
the number of new stores set up in the
first six weeks of the pandemic grew by
more than sixty percent compared to the
previous six weeks
we saw heinz ketchup within i think a
week or two of kova hitting setting up a
store on shopify to sell heinz at home
in the uk we saw lint chocolate go
direct to consumers for the first time
inspired by the chinese model shopify
aims to create an ecosystem which
integrates e-commerce with social media
what we're trying to do is simplify all
of it which want to make it as an easy
thing to do to have one centralized
inventory and figure out which product
should get pushed where and if you're
seeing traffic at your online store
coming from pinterest we're going to
tell you you should activate the
pinterest channel and you should push
product directly to pinterest to better
engage with that audience but i think
we're just at the early stages of social
commerce and i think people are
beginning to understand that there's a
real opportunity here not just to meet
new brands connect with new brands but
also to buy from those brands
by being better connected to their
customers brands can work out not just
what they want to buy but where they
want to shop
take one of shopify's merchants the shoe
company all birds during the pandemic
when many brands were shutting up shop
all birds was opening stores
you hear terms like well offline and
online are competing and online is
hurting offline you would never hear
that from all birds because at the end
of the day what they're trying to do is
create a great experience build a great
brand and sell you great shoes and
however you purchase whatever means or
channels you utilize to do so they're
happy with all those kind of feed into
each other
the future retailers retail everywhere
if you want to sell to my mom you gotta
have a great brick-and-mortar experience
because my mother prefers to buy that
way but my sister who's in her early 20s
she is looking to purchase things on
instagram
it means the store isn't dead
it would just be reimagined to provide
an entirely new type of experience
they're great for providing what we call
brand theater
they're great for providing a live
experience with the customer and to have
expert
sort of
stylist level staff who can really help
the customer in a way that the internet
cannot nike has adapted its stores to
create a bespoke service for the
customer thanks to the information on
their digital profile
and the store presents yet another
channel to capture their data
in the midst of pandemic it opened a
huge store in paris you go in and
immediately it offers you interactive
experiences
it's mingling both online and offline
data and the whole point is to make the
experience of shopping at nike more
intimate more direct and more kind of
one-to-one
[Music]
in-store data can also help inform stock
control ensuring less waste in the
supply chain
improving sustainability as well as
profit margins
according to one recent estimate the
volume of data collected globally is
expected to increase from 33 trillion
gigabytes in 2018 to 175 trillion by
2025
this will be accompanied by rising
concerns about privacy and exploitation
of personal data
it used to be the case that customers
had had to exhibit their loyalty
to
the store that they bought from these
days it's the retailer that has to prove
their loyalty to the shopper and that
loyalty really means looking after their
data
retailers will know increasing amounts
about customers behavior habits and
preferences
this may sit uncomfortably with some
but one thing is for sure
the inevitability that this retail
revolution will be driven by your data
i'm henry tricks i write the schumpeter
column at the economist
you can read my special report on the
future of shopping
on the link opposites
please don't forget to subscribe and
thanks for watching